hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to lawn mowing
simulator yes
we've come back where am i what am i
doing i don't know
hold
no
no back what no no no no no
no no escape i'm just hitting escape no
no
no
no no no no
no what
sting no
no
no
okay
so they have dinosaur dlc
right
dinosaur dlc that means that i can mow a
lawn
when there are dinosaurs roaming free in
the area which of course sounds
freaking awesome
i love that
i love that weather let's make it
overcast ground damage vehicle damage
fuel ground check i don't know i don't
even remember what these are but i know
that there's going to be dinosaurs dino
safari dlc out now it's weird that they
say that to me given that i've bought
this dlc also look at that
never mind
is that a real dino
is it just sitting there is it not
actually going to be chasing me i
thought that i would there's one out
there okay
i might have been right okay okay okay
okay okay all right okay cool cool
cool cool cool cool
[Laughter]
all right
wow
is that a dinosaur
oh
why are you telling me to sprint
i don't like that
i don't i'm gonna say this right now i
don't like that
that's spooky hi are you gonna be upset
if i
mow here
oh you're just silly ain't you i saw uh
wait
stop telling me to sprint um
are you just a statue
are these just animatronics
is this all a lie
have you lied to me
i bought this entire dlc under the
contingency that there would be t-rex's
chasing me down and you're telling me
that i'm only mowing in the area where
there are fake t-rexes
are you kidding me
this is a bunch of malarkey i
legitimately bought this under the all
right maybe maybe they'll be mad once i
actually start mowing
it'll use a sting trimmer
i can do the whole goddamn thing like
this
wow
[Music]
now that's something
oops
[Music]
it does have a certain satisfaction to
it but i was really hoping that this
would add an element that i was missing
in power wash simulator which was like
this idea that
there is something dark and why am i so
low in the
what's going on with my camera it's like
drifting that doesn't make any sense
hold on a second
nah
this is what we get no i'm not gonna do
that there we go
that's probably better
hi
welcome to the video i'm gonna get
started with this
i don't even remember how i play
how do i put this away
okay string trimmer all right here we go
z to start engine
z to start
getting rio
i t
t
okay
cut height
four and a half if you want to get off
press q
okay engage cutting deck z to engage
blades there we go
now we got it
okay
hey good thing i did that edge okay
well this is awfully lovely but it
doesn't get me any closer to the danger
that i was perceiving it's not that i
want the danger or like the danger it's
a video game after all so it wouldn't
really matter if i like it or not the
fact of the matter is i was promised
that there were going to be some
dinosaurs that i was going to have to
avoid when you get a dlc that says dino
safari dlc
i'm assuming that you're introducing
some level of threat to the game that is
going to allow me to be pursued by
dinosaurs
in fact i don't even know why i'm doing
this area i should take the fight
straight to the dinosaurs
is this bush in the way
no it's not
man i'm slow
[Music]
do i have a sprint on this
is this [ __ ] really not gonna come
after me
is this guy really not interested in
killing me because i'm really interested
in it killing me
that sounds weird but
legitimately i am hey hey ugly
hey
hey
i can't hear you i got headphones on hey
hey
hey
why do you move in the i'm overloading
my engine no i'm not
shut up
i don't even know what that means hey
hey
i see your footsteps clearly you walked
over here
clearly you're mid-stride this doesn't
make any sense that you're not moving
kill me
eat me
you need me
you're not gonna do anything
at least this will be good thumbnail i
can i can make it i can photoshop my
face on this face and then the dinosaurs
in the background and i can have my
tradition yeah there perfect yeah good
good good
maybe one of the other maps raptor
enclosure that sounds dangerous
okay
get in turn it on hold for a very long
time for some reason throttle up
cut height will be
four and a half
it's a raptor
down engage
hey pal hey how you doing
you're just a statue
great i'm guessing this isn't a world
where there actually are dinosaurs that
have been made this is a world
what'd you just say to me
oh
excuse me oh i'm sorry you got some
attitude oh i'm sorry oh pardon me
or don't a moi
oh i'm sorry
all right fine whatever
whatever
this is lame
this is lame why would they have the
thousand ten thousand volt thing if they
weren't going to at least have some kind
of
way
that these dinosaurs were gonna kill you
amy
it lied to me
it said that you could
i assumed that you could
i assume that you could move and run
away from dinosaurs and that's not the
case
i wonder if there are cheat codes for
this game and let me see something real
quick game speed game speed 6.95
that was more than the dlc
[ __ ] um
drastic world evolution 2
i play jurassic world evolution
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to jurassic world evolution
2. i don't know what you're talking
about it's always been this i have been
looking forward to this game coming out
for a very long time i've always known
that i wanted to play this when it came
out because i loved the first one when
it was came out and now this one is here
and it has come out oh my god look at
the goddamn dinosaurs
what chaos theory mode allows
what if nah
nah i'm gonna do campaign
here we are where i always wanted to be
you know what's best about this no i
guess an introduction is in order hold
on
subtitles
you'll be working with the experts this
is claire deering and owen grady you
could call me a dinosaur wrangler though
officially i'm an animal behaviorist
that's not crispr that's not crisp
equipped with both a ranger team 4x4 and
a capture team helicopter hmm
but
okay this
bam
done
we may have trouble tracking this
dinosaur from the ground and even more
trouble if we're lucky enough to find it
then the sensible thing is to take a
capture team helicopter
you can drink it from the air am i
flying this thing why am i flying
why why would i why would you put me in
charge of flying this where am i going
am i going to go get a dinosaur this
doesn't have anything to do with mowing
lawns all right time to go get a dino
oh
how do i turn how do i
there we go okay then aim mode
oh my
i'm on a wreck it uh i'm all wreck it
here we go shoo
nice i missed
gonna be hard to get in the water
damn you
get sedatized
there we go
it is currently drowning okay
transport you
deliver berry boy
to
well i mean he seems to be aquatic so i
think we're gonna just plop him right
back in the water
[Music]
you happy
i instantly recognize this dinosaur kind
of hard to forget once you've been
trapped in a room with one huh we
couldn't save that baryonyx
but we can certainly help this one
i mean you know to be perfectly honest
aren't all these representations of
these dinosaurs now completely flawed
didn't we just recently in the past few
years come up with new ways to
visualize their muscular structure and
so it's not just
skeleton
okay what do i do place down a piscivore
feeder ensure the baron onyx can access
it all right episcopore
feeder
episcopor what is a pig oh he is aquatic
why does that cost a hundred thousand
dollars that seems incredibly
inefficient
man whatever i get five fish for a
hundred thousand dollars
that cost me a hundred thousand dollars
good to go on this
copy okay we need to get a full
assessment of the dinosaur's health
utilize a ranger team vehicle
okay we'll help you get a status of the
animal's overall welfare
then we can plan our next move
i'm coming baby
i mean i've always been more of a just
make it up as i go kind of guy
i'll tell you what
if this doesn't work we'll try your way
oh that sort of sounds like a plan
uh what do i do when i'm waterlogged
what do i do when i'm waterlogged inside
of a dinosaur enclosure oh god no
oh no
ah
hey boss oh no
oh no
hey
dude
oh yeah you might want to look at behind
you man
oh no
um
hey buddy yeah get the fish
flare
i don't know if the flare gun's gonna do
anything aim mode right let's get a
status check
oh yeah
missing while we can't replicate what we
had on the island we still have to do
what we can to get dinosaurs more
comfortable with their current
surroundings here in arizona arizona
what do uh what what what do my guys
here do uh that's the question let's
take a photo of this
oh yes nice
ooh
baryonyx attacking bar team wait wait
hold hold on
whoa
what
what you're assuming a lot of things
about this photo um
i don't know what you mean by attacking
uh the team because clearly uh
okay that's bad
i'm just getting
money out of this god the money stay
there buddy you just stay there we are
freaking ranking in the money raking in
the money oh what a beaut
what a view
a beaut of a dino why are you coming
behind
yeah that's pretty good what's up buddy
where's your bell
oh god oh god hey hey whoa that's a good
picture
hey pal hey
okay um
listen uh
friend
guys okay it's drowning oh
wow look at that i think we're out of
the water now so it's it's possible that
we can get out of here
oh it's a nice one hey my composition
bonuses should be higher than that
these are pretty good picks
look at the sun on that
oh
that's pretty nice okay um i think we
can get out of here now i think no no no
forget it forget it forget it forget it
[Applause]
hey bud hey buddy
all right bye yeah you keep looking at
him pal you keep looking at him let me
out let me out look oh god there we go
i probably could have just backed out
yep i could
okay
he needs a rock
that's what he needs he needs what is
that oh my door that's that's my door
okay rock um
rock
rock
can i rotate it yeah i can't
rock wham rock [ __ ]
rock
nice okay i got rocks what do i need for
its comfort
missing rock it has rock what do you
mean it's missing rock it's got rock
right there maybe it needs more rock do
you need more rock
how about that
is that good enough rock
hey there we go okay cool
we've gotta monitor these dinosaurs more
closely that means setting up a ranger
post inside their enclosure it sounds
crazy i know but this will work trust me
uh-huh
okay ranger team a sign
all right good luck i guess
i'm getting reports of dinosaurs running
freely around the facility claire what
the reports may be accurate but they
don't paint a complete picture of our
current status we'll start by
tranquilizing one of the dinosaurs from
the helicopter okay
okay cool
why are they just free roaming in
arizona and why aren't we shooting them
with high caliber bullets
or something like that
and also please tell me i can just put
this in the same enclosure as the other
one because that would be great
come here you [ __ ]
i don't even know it's been hit
how do i get it again
you got hook worms i just happen to get
i happen to get the one with hook worms
how do i get it into the
catcher team
capture team capture team
capture team
no
capture team
how did i do capture team again how was
i how um
operations no
oh god
oh god how do i not remember how to do
that i just did it oh god how do i not
remember
oh god captured you you have that
you're the capture team you
oh i need to get all of them
that does
that checks out
take some of this
and one of these no don't run don't run
don't run don't run don't run
don't run it's not gonna help you
it's not gonna help you if you run don't
even try to run it's not gonna help you
okay i did it
now what do we do construct a new
enclosure got it
fences new enclosure i don't know
i'm assuming i just do it here right
[Music]
okay
um
isolate the triceratops from other
dinosaurs ah
oh god how do i get you i don't i still
don't remember how to get you
they're gonna wake up they're gonna wake
up
yeah
i'm going back to the main menu
i don't want to play the [ __ ]
tutorial i know how to play even though
i literally just said i still don't
remember how to get you
canada
canada starting
hey arrival point
and wham okay we got that how do i get
dinos in here where are my dinos
where do i get dinos how do i get
dinosaurs in here
give me some goddamn oh
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] put some [ __ ]
dinosaurs in here put some [ __ ]
dinosaurs
that's how you transport
that's how you transport
oh
god i'm so stupid ugh all right you know
what i'm just going to stick with this
give me a second give me a second give
me a second give me a goddamn second
here
[Music]
i wanted lawnmow you know what
i'm going back because i know there are
some people that only watch the
beginning of this and then skip to the
end of this
i want people to be really confused
because they're going to only watch the
beginning and then they're only going to
watch the end and here i am at the end
and to be perfectly honest they're just
not going to understand what happened
but that doesn't matter to me because
it's all cool because i
know what's happening man i'm so happy
that i'm playing this dino safari dlc it
really you know at first i wasn't too
into it because i was disappointed at
the fact that the dinosaurs aren't
actually alive but to be perfectly
honest you know i i get it i get why
because it would just be too dangerous
it's more of like an educational
explorational park which is fair i
i get it i understand
i'm going too low i forget how to raise
there we go
i get it
i just get it
what is whoa
anyway
i get it
and that's why i'm just happy to be able
to play a nice relaxing game like this
holy [ __ ]
it's just plain old lovely
it's just lovely and while i wish i
could just flood this episode with
non-stop
action-patched lawn mowing potential
and even though it didn't have
everything that i actually wanted within
it and even though i'm crushingly
disappointed by the idea that it's
letting me down once again because i
vaguely remember you letting me down
before not that i remember it not that
i'm ever going to not forgive you for it
but i remember something about being
disappointed by this game or maybe it's
that the disappointment that i feel
right now is so crushing that nothing
could ever live up to my expectations
and the fact that i would even try means
that i am the fool and not you
doesn't mean that i can't enjoy life for
what it is at this moment hey hey
all right anyway
[Music]
i really did think that this was going
to be
more uh action-packed than
the dlc suggested it really did seem
like you were going to get chased by
dinosaurs and i really don't think that
i'm the only one that was fooled by this
idea um because i couldn't have been
there's no way that i could have been
other people looking at that must have
been like oh god i have to have some
kind of a survival mode where i have to
finish mowing a lawn before the
dinosaurs kill me or i have to somehow
work around the dinosaurs so that they
don't get hurt by my dinosaur mowing you
know what i mean this is a thick bush
goal god
anyway
i'm gonna end this episode here uh glad
i stuck through it for as long as i did
you know would have been really odd if i
you know just bailed in the middle of
this
for something completely unrelated but
hey this is where we are and i'm really
happy about that so thank you everybody
so much for watching hope you enjoyed
the game hope you enjoyed this video let
me know what you thought down in the
comments below uh
and yeah if you want to see more
lawnmower simulator i'm always going to
be here and for it you know how i am
about this game just like a die hard fan
through and through uh really nothing
will ever stop me from loving this game
so i'm gonna love it hard and i'm gonna
love it fast uh thank you again
uh link's in the description for the
game itself and other cool stuff that
i'm doing remember i've got a podcast
with bob and wade called distractable
i've got a podcast with tyler called go
i've got a secret podcast that no one's
ever discovered yet that if you find it
you win a grand prize i can't tell you
what the prize is legally but there is a
prize and the podcast definitely exists
so go search for it uh just listen for
my voice on random podcasts everywhere
you will find it eventually thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
i don't know what the [ __ ] this video is
uh good luck
editing it good luck
[Music]
you